bonjour nous sommes le 2 octobre
nouvelle édition du journal de la
rédaction de tv fils édition de fin de
semaine aujourd'hui c'est jean jacques
simon qui va nous accompagner lors de la
prochaine demi heure bonjour et
bienvenue en plateau jean jacques simon
dit jacquot exactement ce qu'ils
connaissent parce que vous êtes une
figure un petit peu de cette ville
nouvelle de saint quentin en yvelines
on vous croise quand même de temps en
temps on me saint quentin en yvelines et
vous signez à cet ouvrage ma place au
soleil 30 ans de vie commune avec le
sida il y est question de votre passé de
toxicomane de la maladie de votre
quotidien avec elle
également on va y venir tout à l'heure
dans ce journal pour le moment voici les
titres de cette édition du vendredi pour
vibrer au rythme des performances des
bleus en coupe du monde de rugby est la
ville de bois d'arcy propose des
retransmissions en direct et une de nos
équipes a suivi hier le match france
canada
les chiens aiment l'eau et c'est bien
connu et depuis peu une société propose
de soigner leur petite douleur et autres
courbatures lors de ses ancêtres
d'accoître et une reportages insolites
tout à l'heure et puis nous reviendrons
sur l'essentiel de l'actualité de la
semaine comme chaque vendredi campagne
des régionales déplacement d'un à juppé
dans les yvelines ou encore le rôle de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
à dans la découverte de l'eau sur mars
pour débuter ces images les étudiants de
l'université de versailles-saint-quentin
justement qui sont mécontents et qui le
font savoir en garant leur voiture dans
le parc situé juste derrière leur
bibliothèque un parc habituellement
réservé aux piétons c'était ce vendredi
matin il entendait s'opposer la hausse
du prix du parking passé de 18 euros
pour un an à 60 euros pour deux ans les
véhicules ont été déplacées à la demande
de la police les étudiants ont en tout
cas lancé une pétition qu'ils nous
entendent remettre au président de
l'université
on a pris ça quand quand on fait la
porte du bâtiment d'alembert puisque
l'année dernière était gratuite parce
que la porte était défectueuse la porte
du bâtiment dalembert a refermé
quand on encore que les étudiants ont
commencé à vouloir s'inscrire pour les
cartes de parking du compte que c'était
passé a souvent tour on a eu aucune
information là-dessus puisque voilà
c'est notre président merci des caprices
vraiment la décision tout seul 109
mais qui que ce soit nous avons contacté
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines nous a précisé
que cette décision avait été votée en
conseil d'administration donc avec des
représentants des étudiants au début du
mois de juillet l'université qui nous a
aussi informé que la mise à disposition
de places de parking par un
établissement n'est pas une obligation
l'augmentation des coûts est justifiée
par la sécurité est également pour
renforcer les contrôles d'accès et la
surveillance donc un mot de sport à
présent et les bleus qui jouaient tiers
face au canada c'est du rugby à bois
d'arcy un écran géant a été installé à
l'abri blues pour retransmettre les
matchs du quinze de france reportage de
michael et demi d'euros et de mélanie
poker la coupe du monde de rugby
passionnent des millions de français à
bois d'arcy un écran géant a été
installé à l'abri blues spécialement
pour cet événement tous les matches de
l'équipe de france sont retransmis en
fait là on suit juste principalement
l'équipe de france si jamais on n'est
pas qualifiés pour là le reste on verra
on avisera au fur à mesure voir quel
match son programme ou pas et de quoi
qu'il en soit là la finale sera de toute
façon programmée jeudi soir pour le
match entre le quinze de france et
l'équipe du canada une trentaine de
supporteurs sont venus encourager les
bleus c'est bien l'écran on discute avec
des gens en compte du monde c'est simple
on peut rester chez soi devant sa télé
un canapé mais a le rugby est un sport
de contact et de partage donc on est
mieux ensemble
en 80 minutes les supporters français
présents dans la salle ont vibré au
rythme les actions tricolores malgré
quelques passages à vide pendant la
rencontre les bleus ont remporté la
victoire
un résultat qui donne le sourire aux
supporters public on a vu un très beau
collectif des joueurs qui étaient
stratégiques
c'était quand même pas un mauvais match
mais il faut qu'il soit il faut qu'il
soit leur technique qui soigne les bases
un patient par beaucoup d'erreurs de
débutants l'abri blues de oued arcis
retransmettra le prochain match des
bleus contre l'irlande
une rencontre programmée le dimanche 11
octobre à 17h45 la salle attend plus
d'une centaine de personnes pour
l'événement ont regardé justement ce
résumé du match avec jacko l'invité
d'aujourd'hui et jean jacques simon
eggly un petit peu vous suivez un peu
par la force des choses on ne peut pas
l'éviter en ce moment oui vous êtes
satisfait des performances des bleus
entre satisfait pas de favori on y croit
on y croit il faut améliorer notre de
king mes mots n'a non pas voulu je suis
pas favori pour la compétition d'un
favori non j'irais pas jusqu'a donna si
les japonais japonais les japonaises ont
fait un bon début de compétition non
plus le japonais de nakhonay petit mais
un reportage insolite
à présent certains se penche au chevet
de leurs animaux de compagnie et il
apparaît que les chiens aussi ont besoin
de se détendre de soulager leur
articulation avec l'âge c'est ce que
propose un centre dacquois technique
c'est à gaz rend dans les yvelines donc
c'est signé sephora namani et patrick
jacques de dixmude c'est veulent un
cortège de 12 ans vient une fois par
semaine dans un centre d'accueil
technique pour chiens souffrant
d'arthrose ce seigneur à retrouver
souplesse et agilité en moyenne dix
séances sont nécessaires et les
améliorations apparaissent dès la
troisième fois
j'accompagne les animaux dans un
mieux-être en utilisant les
caractéristiques physiques de l'eau en
fête qui ont la flottaison là le
drainage par le par le massage de l'eau
sur la résistance sur le corps etc
c'est plus une détente musculaire une
mobilité accrue c'est à dire qu'on va
augmenter à l'animal d'avoir une
meilleure mobilité on travaille aussi
sur la performance performance
respiratoires musculaires la puissance
aussi parce que la résistance de l'eau
permet à l'animal de travailler
davantage
dix centres dacquois techniques non
vétérinaire existe en france carole
lefebvre a ouvert le sien en avril
dernier avec une expérience d'auxiliaire
vétérinaire
une initiative bien accueillie par les
professionnels comme les propriétaires
canins j'ai bien remarqué qu'avec ça
n'existait déjà pas en france et quand
j'ai travaillé chez les vétérinaires
c'est vrai que j'ai constaté que après
des soins médicaux il n'existait pas de
l'espace détente bien-être pour les
animaux de plus c'est vrai que quand
j'ai travaillé en société d'incinération
j'ai préparé les animaux pour que les
familles fassent leur deuil
souvent j'entendais des regrets des gens
qui disaient si j'avais pu faire ceci ou
cela ce centre dacquois technique
s'adresse à tous les canins juniors
seniors handicapés sportif dans le but
d'apporter du bien-être de la remise en
forme ou d'accompagner les fins de vie
en plus des deux activités principales
la cua training et le massage le centre
propose des services comme le watchdog
et la garderie avant de passer à
l'entretien de cette édition comme
chaque vendredi nous passons en revue
l'actualité de la semaine résumé en
images des principales informations que
nous avons développées chaque soir en
direct à 18 heures du lundi au jeudi le
montage est signée xavier jaglin
matraquage fiscal réforme brouillonne
l'ancien premier ministre n'a pas fait
dans la demi-mesure mercredi soir à
poissy alain juppé accueillis par le
maire et conseiller départemental karl
olive et applaudi par les militants et
les sympathisants sous les regards des
ténors républicains des yvelines j'ai
ici beaucoup d'amis parmi les élus bien
sûr parmi la population
j'étais très heureux bien sûr de te
sentir ce mouvement d'adhésion
enfin la route est longue c'était une
première au niveau régional les antennes
ile-de-france du medef de la chambre de
commerce et de la cgpme ont décidé de
s'unir pour interpeller les candidats de
tous les partis à la région ile de
france
durant deux heures les candidats ont pu
exposer leur projet mais surtout écouter
les propositions un premier dialogue
entre les candidats et les acteurs
économiques du territoire en vue d'un
avant siens sur un projet commun au
profit du territoire
c'était une promesse de campagne du
nouveau maire philippe benassaya ce
matin le maire le maire de bois d'arcy a
inauguré les locaux de la police
municipale
la brigade compte à présent quatre
agents budget de ce projet 45000 euros
l'insécurité présenta les pas
catastrophique sur bois d'arcy loin de
là mais on matière de sécurité il faut
prévenir et puis c'est la création d'un
service public supplémentaire et en
temps de crise offrir un service de
proximité depuis ce soir si bien c'est
quand même à plus attention devant la
mairie de trappes après un premier
mouvement juillet les agents municipaux
de la commune étaient en grève
aujourd'hui plus de 80 personnes se sont
réunies sur le parvis de l'hôtel de
ville pour protester contre une
modification de leur congé exceptionnel
ce qu'on demande c'est de ne pas toucher
aux quelques acquis kona les acquis
c'est pas compliqué hein c'est les gens
qui ont des médailles et 15 jours de
congés et nous continuons en politique
un accord pour développer les logements
en milieu rural a été signé aujourd'hui
à l'hôtel du département de versailles
ce protocole concerne plus de 150
villages yvelinois avec une population
de moins de 2000 habitants
parmi les communes concernées on
retrouve bailly toussus-le-noble rennes
moulin tient malgré lyon ou encore les
essarts le roi pour soutenir le
programme le département a décidé de
développer une enveloppe de 2,2 millions
d'euros
nous disposons actuellement de trois
logements qui sont derrière l'ancienne
poste et qui sont inoccupés condé
moulieras quand on fera le plateau
urbain ça veut dire que pendant une
année
on peut les mettre à disposition à
condition que ya un organisme social qui
gère qui accompagne les personnes qui
sont dans ces logements aux personnes
âgées sentent isolés
isolement ça n'est pas simplement en
domicile à la maison c'est également des
personnages et en hébergement collectif
qui lorsqu on va les voir nous disent je
n'ai pas de visite
je vois des personnes qui viennent me
voir pour faire des soins pour s'occuper
de moi mais je n'ai personne qui vient
nous voir tous moi dominique en a plus
qu'assez en deux ans c'est la troisième
fois que les jardins familiaux depuis en
course ont cambriolé l'année dernière
dix mille euros de matériel avait été
dérobée et encore 13 milles en mai 2014
malheureusement notre instrument sam lui
n'est pas n'est pas vraiment directement
concerné par découverte mais en tout cas
la découverte du sel permet à l'eau de
rester liquide ou de devenir demain qui
s'appelle le perchlorate dont on a
beaucoup parlé hier pendant la
conférence de brèves et bien sam ça a
été le seul instrument finalement de
curiosity qui permet la détection de ce
perchlorate et en fait on l'a mis en
évidence lors de nos premières à ce que
la foire aux vins c'est vraiment
l'occasion servi bonnes affaires lors
des bonnes notes safer pas forcément
parce que aujourd'hui l'offre et est
gigantesque entre les hypers les
cavistes
ce qui est intéressant c'est justement
ce panel sur une période assez réduite
de choses qu'on ne trouve pas forcément
toute l'année de l'eau sur mars
l'accueil des réfugiés des vols aux
jardins familiaux voilà pour
quelques-uns des sujets que nous avons
abordé cette semaine ce qui est un sujet
particulier qui a retenu votre attention
dans l'actualité on vous suivez même au
niveau national en ce moment non mais là
sur ce qu'on vient de voir là l'idée
d'aller voler dans les jardins communaux
c'est quand même ça montre qu'il ya déjà
on est déjà un niveau de deux crises
important car visiblement pour la faire
la suite de ce reportage les les
cambrioleurs ont été arrêtés quelques
jours plus tard il se trouve qu'ils
avaient des puces gps qui avaient été
installés sur matériel qui a été volé
donc forcément retrouver dans le reste
de l'actualité également cette semaine
on va revenir à présent sur le week-end
dernier c'est à montigny-le-bretonneux
une messe a été célébrée en arabe et ce
en soutien aux réfugiés syriens et
irakiens juste après on parle de cet
ouvrage
à
c'est une première au diocèse des
yvelines samedi dernier à montigny le
bretonneux
la messe était célébrée en arabe dans
l'assistance des syriens irakiens et
libanais réfugié en france et pour eux
cela faisait des mois qu'on n'avait pas
participé à un office dans leur langue
c'est très important pour nous de prix
en arabe
nous sommes en paix on peut vraiment se
libérer et prier à l'autre facile parce
notre aujourd'hui je suis dans une
chorale je chante en français on à
passable dans notre pays c'est plus
important la liberté un pays qu'ils ont
fui il ya plusieurs mois à cause de leur
foi
l'importance de la communauté des
chrétiens d'orient qui s'agrandit avec
l'accueil récent de réfugiés incité les
responsables du diocèse a organisé cette
messe dorénavant il y aura une messe
tous les mois en arabe à saint-quentin
de manière à permettre que ces chrétiens
qui arrive ne subissent pas la double
peine après celle d'avoir été chassés de
chez eux de devoir en plus perdre leurs
racines leur culture notre souci c'est
de leur offrir la possibilité d'être
accueilli dans leur langue dans leur
culture avec leur manière de prier
certainement le message du pape a eu un
impact sur l'ensemble des paroisses du
monde et je trouve que la réponse des
chrétiens ce que j'en entends ce que
j'envoie est une réponse très ouverte et
en même temps très responsable une
responsabilité qui passe par
l'accompagnement dans les procédures
administratives et dans la vie de tous
les jours
pour cette première messe selon le rite
maronite 250 personnes étaient présentes
un moment qu'ils ont pu apprécier
ensemble autour de leur religion
le prochain l'office se fera le 10
octobre en l'église saint martin on en
vient donc à cet ouvrage ma place au
soleil signé par jean jacques simon que
l'on connaît sous le nom de jaco qu'on
connaît également sur cette antenne
puisqu'on s'étaient rencontrés il ya une
petite dizaine d'années sur saint
quentin en yvelines déjà pour un premier
témoignage vous vivez depuis 30 ans
maintenant avec le sida pourquoi vous
avez voulu tout simplement parler de ça
dans l ouvrage pourquoi avoir voulu
coucher sur papier aujourd'hui
en fait ça commence par lorsque j'ai
écrit le premier les un premier livre là
en 2006 et iselle de l'euzière donc en
2004 j'ai écrit j avais eu quelques bons
retours du coup ça m'a donné leur vie
j'ai continué d'écrire j'ai fait ce
manuscrit
par la suite il s'est passé des choses
qui ont fait que je n'ai pas fait j'ai
pas cherché dirigé par rechercher
d'éditeurs puisque ma maison d'édition
avait disparu danger par rechercher
d'éditeurs et par un concours de
circonstance par une amie qui m'a dit ah
tiens là lui elle m'a dit ça serait bien
de le faire publier j'ai essayé de le
faire publier on va éditer parce que
dans le premier ouvrage il n'était pas
nécessairement question de la maladie du
tout alors que c'est l'objet central de
ce deuxième livre vous le faites avec
une certaine légèreté aussi dans le ton
dans la façon d'aborder la maladie c'est
pas un livre on sent que vous vivez pas
ça comme quelque chose de grave de
dramatique aux failles css est assez
léger finalement même dans l'écriture
donc la façon dont vous parlez de la
maladie vous vous dites que vous vivez
avec ce singe d'ailleurs ouais mais
c'est à dire que si j'avais été
transfusé dans les années où le sang
contaminé tourner pas mal dans les
hôpitaux
je pense que je n'aurai pas du tout la
même approche du problème et qu'on
serait sûrement pas là en train d'en
parler parce que j'aurais peut-être fait
d'autres
d'autres choses militer montée des
associations je sais pas mais là il se
trouve que j'étais toxicomane personne
m'a planté une aiguille dans le bras de
finition c'était dans les années 80
exactement mais et en plus de tout à
l'époque où j'ai décidé justement
d'arrêter la toxicomanie d'arrêter la
délinquance et tout ça
ma vie est devenue meilleure donc c'est
un peu ancien dauphin antinomiques
paradoxal de dire d'un côté j'étais
malade mais d'un autre côté ma vie
allait mieux vu qu'avant ma vie
toxicomanes ne pouvait m'amener que dans
une
mais vous aviez conscience justement à
l'époque avec la toxicomanie les
seringue que vous pouviez attraper le
sida on était dans les années 80 c'était
le tout début de la maladie qu'on
connaissait très très mal en fait bien
sûr mais on en parlait déjà conscience
vous il ya un risque
d'un côté on en avait conscience d'un
côté d'un autre côté dans les pharmacies
fallait quasiment laissé sa carte
d'identité pour avoir une seringue et
pour avoir une seringue c'était la croix
et la bannière
donc forcément d'un seul coup et en plus
cela nous les notions médicales étaient
d'un toxicomane n'étaient pas forcément
les meilleurs donc il se peut il se peut
très bien qu'on se dise passer sous
l'eau ça y est c'est bon et que les et
du coup les seringue ce pas s'échanger à
cette époque là assez facilement c'est
comme ça vous avez contracté la maladie
va juste faire une petite parenthèse
parce qu'aujourd'hui le sida ne fait
plus vraiment peur aux jeunes les jeunes
ne se protègent plus pour ce qu'il
attrape par par rapport sexuel
les jeunes se protègent plus le sida
fait plus peur on en parle finalement
assez peu de prévention aussi vous vous
réagissez comme ans quand vous voyez ça
vous qui vivez avec la maladie depuis 30
ans vous dites qu'ils sont inconscients
qui réalisent pas c'est laid c'est le
deuxième effet malheureusement de tout
ce qui est trithérapie tout ce qui est
traitement on se dit aujourd'hui on vit
très bien avec moi c'est vous avez
exactement des halles à la question et
la réponse est savoir tous que c'est
urgent à l'époque des traités rapide
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu un une baisse
il ya eu deux choses il ya le ce truc
des trithérapies cette arrivée des
trithérapies qui a été très importante
mais aussi le 2e sidaction qui a été un
peu un échec dû à toute une histoire qui
a eu entre acteurs et le ministre de la
santé de l'époque avait pas tenu ses
engagements et cetera et cetera donc où
tu enfin il ya eu un espèce de deux
choses qui s'est passé qui affecte d'un
seul coup le sida qui déjà avait été
présenté dans un premier temps comme la
peste des homosexuels et des toxicomanes
donc déjà l'attaché de presse bonjour on
se retrouvait avec une affiche qui était
assez
et c'est pour ça qu'à prendre on est
arrivés des années plus tard avec la
bataille entre sida téléthon le cil
d'acide
non c'est des maladies point barre c'est
pas et le sida est une maladie qui n'est
ni comme la lèpre ni comme le choléra
des choses qu'on a éradiqué
c'est pas du tout des trucs qu'on risque
d'attraper en allant fin fond de
l'afrique ou quoi que ce soit tu peut
l'attraper à neuilly ou n'importe où et
il rêvait que c'est difficile à vivre
avec ces temps difficiles c'est pas
parce que moi et en plus moi il faut pas
maintenant il faut pas faire un cas une
généralité de mon cas ça serait une
grave erreur j'ai vécu avec 12 t4 les
défenses immunitaires dans la mondre en
avoir minimum 5 cents j'ai vécu avec 4
donc faut pas se baser non plus sur moi
si là je fait étalage tout de suite là
de toutes les douleurs que j'ai eus
revenant marchand un peu partout du à
tous les traitements que j'ai pris et
cetera
ça va sûrement un accueil aux heures
j'ai pas envie de vivre ça et il ya
plein de choses qu'on n'a pas forcément
envie de vivre parce que c'est des
molécules qui sont fortes les
médicaments ces médicaments là et qu'on
une liste d'effets secondaires qui est
il limitait quasiment donc à presse au
petit bonheur la chance mais on peut
très bien se retrouver mois juste pour
finir jo l'exemple d'une infirmière qui
s'est piqué à une époque où j'avais un
traitement de la dernière chance et
qu'on me faisait des piqûres deux fois
par jour une fois elle s'est piqué avec
une des seringue
on l'a mis un mois sous mon traitement
la première chose qui m'a dit quand elle
est revenue au bout d'un mois qu'ils ont
su que c'était négatif et c'est à je te
regarderai plus jamais de la même façon
elle m'a dit moi pendant un mois j'ai
cru mourir
vingt-quatre heures sur vingt-quatre ans
elle a eu et on ignore le défendeur du
mode debug de savate du vent de la tête
des crampes du moral qui est dans les
chaussettes
la totale quoi c'était vraiment un
espèce d'accumulation de tout ce qu'on
ne pourrait pas aimé en même temps donc
après si quelqu'un a envie de tenter ça
c'est son choix je dirais mais je
voudrais revenir aussi à l'histoire que
réussite et vous écrivez dans cet
ouvrage sur les premières années avec la
maladie parce que les premières années
avec la maladie voulait passer en prison
oui ce qu'on a dit vous étiez
toxicomanes et faisait des
allers-retours avec la prison de bois
d'arcy entre autres voilà notamment
comment vous avez vécu la maladie en
prison en plus dernières années disons
que mon caractère m'a beaucoup aidé à
savoir que j'ai pas fait le choix de me
cacher de dire je suis pas malade ou
quoi j'ai bon voilà j'étais toxicomane
gtg trapèze virus il n'y a pas de honte
spéciale à avoir et j'ai réussi à être
avec des gens cellules qui était
relativement intelligents et avec qui
j'ai pu vivre tout à fait normalement ma
détention ce qui n'est pas le cas de
beaucoup d'autres séropositifs qui ont
vécu dans des fins des trucs vraiment
plus qu'horrible rapport à ceux le rejet
cas d'ailleurs dans le livre chevennes
il ya une nouvelle à la fin qui ne parle
pas de ma vie qui était une nouvelle
qu'on avait fait pour le sidaction pour
un concours de de commandeur et deux
scénarios et dans laquelle j'explique ça
le rejet qui peut y avoir et ça peut
même amener jusqu'à des suicides voire
la mort de quelqu'un quoi c'est ce rejet
de la maladie mais aucun moment où on a
vous avez baissé les bras vous avez
perdu l'espoir parce que je souhaite les
étapes ans parce qu'on pourrait aller
très très longtemps mais vous avez même
fait du cinéma avec olivier megaton bien
aujourd'hui à un protégé de luc besson
j'irai pas que c'est un protégé de luc
besson et je dirais que la lutte besson
l'a aidé à commencer à apprendre
vraiment le travail et que maintenant
c'est juste olivier megaton mais ce soir
était vive et les journaux télévisions
où on marque tekken 3 un film de luc
besson
parce que c'est fatigant c'est le vivier
à gaza qui prendrait un peu à olivier ce
qui appartient au but mais en tout cas
il vous a permis et si vous le défendez
c'est vous êtes encore amis aujourd'hui
afin de défendre une tranche les
panneaux et voilà si vous en parle aussi
bien c'est que vous êtes amis
vous avez monté les marches de la can
avec lui oui ils ont ils m'ont fait cet
honneur pour justement est rempli c'est
en l'an 2000 donc c'était pour moi qu'un
peu symbolique au niveau du passage aux
preuves au nouveau millénaire c'est
quelque chose d'assez exceptionnel on
l'aurait jamais imaginé ça votre passion
raconte justement d'une nouvelle car à
un moment donné quand j'étais dans les
cellules d'isolement à la centrale de
clairvaux
si jamais quelqu'un était rentré m'avait
dit tu sais bien dans 15 ans ou dans dix
ans tu vas aller faire les marches de
cannes et charabi au martinez
j'aurais dit il faut changer de drogue
ou faut faire quelque chose mais vous
devez vous trompez c'est la cellule d'à
côté mais j'aurais pas pousser vrai que
aimer c'est ce que je raconte aussi
c'est n'ayant pas de famille c'est aussi
ça qui me permettait aussi c'est tous
ses amis laqué qui me permettent aussi
d'avancer et de continuer à faire des
choses le web aujourd'hui justement dans
quel état d'esprit vous êtes dans quel
état d'esprit est toujours je suis pas
aujourd'hui fait beau c'est l'état
indien je dirais ça là on fait tout va
bien mission ensemble voit quoi tout va
plutôt bien et moi tous pas tout va
plutôt bien mais quand même je vais dire
quelque chose parce que vous me donner
la possibilité de le faire si je suis
ici en ce moment aujourd'hui ce que ça
me fait plaisir de devenir à montigny
c'est qu'il ya un parcours j'ai un
parcours avec la ville de montigny qui
est pas banal c'est à dire que quand je
suis sortie de postcure en 90 comme il
avait un petit peu d'appréhension par
rapport à ma façon
pas de gérer la drogue mais puisque
c'était réglé mais j'irai les budgets
l'argent le travail extra j'ai été aux
appartements thérapeutiques ici à
montigny le bretonneux opa du lac donc
déjà à ce temps à ce moment là ils m'ont
permis la lie à eux qui est l' agence de
recrutement de parole de l'agent de pôle
emploi dit mon teint à l'époque m'a
trouvé du travail alors que j'habitais
quand même à trappes et elle m'a quand
même trouver du travail c'était le
premier travail que j'ai effectué par la
suite après un licenciement pour '
invalidité je me suis retrouvé à la
maison de quartier du pas du lac où là
alors 4 ap il m'avait trimballer pendant
huit mois en me disant attends attends
va faire des réunions et qu'au bout de
huit mois ils m'ont dit ton projet c'est
pas bien y'a pas de sport dedans et eu
ici à montigny opa du lac en quinze
jours j'étais animateur de maisons de
quartier donc quelque part maintenant
avec tout ce bagage que j'ai accumulée
au niveau de ce qui peut être de la
prévention à savoir que j'étais faire
des interventions que ce soit à l'edhec
école de commerce de lille deux fois
dans les écoles d'infirmières dans pas
mal de deux contextes différents
moi j'ai vraiment envie de monter un
projet de prévention qu'ils soient
surmontés
qu'ils soient sur la ville nouvelle
maintenant après il ya qu'on entend
beaucoup de parole à la télévision quand
les politiques s'expriment en nous
disant que vraiment la prévention c'est
la première des choses dans laquelle il
faut vraiment faire on doit le médecin
en avant mais dans les faits quand vous
écrivez ou que vous envoyez un mail vous
pour proposer un projet qui tient la
route on vous répond votre projet est
très intéressant
néanmoins la prévention n'est pas une
des thématiques à l'ordre du jour et
aujourd'hui ce projet de prévention il
en est où juste pour l'instant on en est
là c'est pour ça que j'en reparle à ce
moment là parce que quand on en arrive à
dire que le la prévention n'est pas une
thématique à l'ordre du jour ça voudrait
dire que la prévention est placé au même
rang que la semaine prévert respect pour
lui ou la semaine des jardins fleuris ou
là la prévention c'est autre chose
la prévention c'est les jeunes qui
partent en sucette la prévention c'est
là c'est l'insécurité la prévention
c'est le trouble à l'ordre public
c'est tous à la prévention donc tous ces
choses là en ce moment là faut quand
même reconnaître que ça va pas dans le
sens du mieux donc si des gens qui
savent de quoi ils parlent se propose
pour pour faire quelque chose à ceux là
dedans accepter les le message est passé
si vous voulez connaître l'histoire de
jacquot c'est avec cet ouvrage
et je précise aussi vous devriez être
fin novembre présent aux pavés du canal
normalement à montigny le bretonneux
puisqu'ils un rendez vous avec les
auteurs locaux qui est en train de se
monter
vous devriez y être présent avec bien
merci beaucoup d'être moi qui est
repassé en plateau pour conclure cette
édition deux informations que nous
développerons dans le journal de lundi
tout d'abord la mobilisation samedi
matin demain des élus de guyancourt
contre la fermeture de la paix mis le
département des yvelines qui gère ces
structures à destination des jeunes
mères veut regrouper les moyens et donc
fusionner pas encore david douillet
plusieurs sites
elle les discussions sont en cours en
attendant à la majorité socialiste de
l'aisne
maintenir une certaine pression sur le
conseil départemental de droite et de
centre-droit
voilà donc cette fois ci la pmi de
guyancourt et puis notre colère et qui
va s'exprimer décidément david douillet
4-2 par les autres couleurs votre colère
qui va s'exprimer ce week end et
dimanche
nous en reparlerons donc l'indicé celle
des motards la fédération des motards en
colère se réunira à saint germain en
laye pour former un cortège allant
jusqu'à versailles ils demandent de
stopper les abaissements de vitesse il
évoque une écologie sans taxer sans
interdiction lundi sur tv fils juste
après le journal vous aussi et vous
aurez aussi rendez vous à 18h30 19h30 à
23h avec le 7-8 sport il sera fait un
petit clin d'oeil au clasico le fameux
clasico entre le psg et l'om le psg qui
n'a toujours pas choisi et jacquot qui
va suivre ce match qui n'a toujours pas
choisi son futur centre d'entraînement
il sera bien dans les yvelines pas
forcément à saint-germain-en-laye
puisque thiverval grignon et poissy
reviennent le plus souvent l'attend dure
depuis des années et david douillet
justement député des yvelines proche du
président du psg milite pour une
installation à poissy et il en a plus
qu'assez
et cette fois ci on l'écouté on est
toujours en contact pour avancer sur le
sujet une chose est sûre il faut pas que
ça dure trop longtemps
voilà parce que notre nos terrasses de
pons y est on a mis le maire de poissy
karl olive de dire est comme moi nous
attendons depuis longtemps et nous avons
des projets sur ce site
le psg en fait partie mais on atteint la
limite du temps voilà il faut vraiment
une décision d'ici au grand maximum la
fin de l'année et je dirais même très
certainement dans le mois qui arrive
en attendant on oublie pas qu ici c'est
paris et qu'il faudra s'imposer au parc
face à marseille un mois de la
programmation de nos confrères de radio
sensations dimanche nicolas kirillovitch
reçoit pour son hebdo la politique jean
paul huchon le président ps de la région
il ne se représentera pas pour un
nouveau mandat mais il défend son bilan
vous n'en verrez pas les images mais en
tout cas vous l'entendrez à la radio et
vous retrouverez ça sur leur chaîne
youtube ce sera à partir de 18h dimanche
il est temps de refermer ce journal pour
reprendre des forces pour lundi très bon
week end